You've studied the human mind,
cognition,
language,
vision,
evolution,
psychology from child to adult,
from the level of individual to the
level of our entire civilization.
So I feel like I can start with a simple
multiple choice question.
What is the meaning of life?
Is it a,
to attain knowledge is Plato said,
b,
to attain power,
as Nisha said.
See to escape death,
as Ernest Becker said,
d,
to propagate our genes as Darwin and
others have said,
he,
there is no meaning as the nihilists
have said,
f knowing the meaning of life is beyond
our cognitive capabilities.
Uh,
Steven pinker said,
based on my interpretation 20 years ago,
and gee,
none of the above,
I'd say eight comes closest,
but I would amend that to attaining not
only knowledge but a fulfillment more
generally.
That is life,
health,
stimulation,
uh,
access to the living,
cultural and social world.
Now this is our meeting of life.
It's not the meaning of life.
If you were to ask our genes,
they're meeting is to propagate copies
of themselves,
but that is distinct from the meaning
that the brain that they lead to sets
for itself.
So to you,
knowledge is a small subset or a large
subset.
It's a large subset,
but it's not the entirety of human
striding because,
uh,
we also want to interact with people we
want to experience beauty,
we want to experience the richness of
the natural world.
Uh,
but uh,
understanding the,
what makes the universe a tech is a,
is way up there for some of us more than
others.
Uh,
certainly for me that's a,
that that's one of the top five.
So is that a fundamental aspect ages
describing your own preference or is
this a fundamental aspect of human
nature is to seek knowledge to a.
In your latest book,
you talk about the,
the,
the power,
the usefulness of rationality and
reason.
So on.
Is that a fundamental nature of human
beings or is it something we should just
strive for it both.
It is,
we're,
we're capable of striving for it because
it is one of the things that make us
what we are homo sapiens wise,
man,
we are unusual among animals in the
degree to which we acquire knowledge and
use it to survive.
We,
we make tools,
we strike agreements,
uh,
via language,
we extract poisons,
we predict the behavior of animals,
we try to get at the workings of plants
and when I say we,
I don't just mean we in the modern west,
but we as a species everywhere,
which is how we've managed to occupy
every niche on the planet and how we've
managed to drive other animals to,
and the refinement of reason in pursuit
of human wellbeing,
of a health,
happiness,
social richness,
cultural richness is our,
uh,
our main challenge in the present that
is using our intellect,
using our knowledge to figure out how
the world works,
how we work in order to make discoveries
and strike agreements that make us all
better off in the long run.
Right?
And you do that almost undeniably,
and I'm in a data driven way and your
recent book,
but I'd like to focus on the artificial
intelligence aspect of things and not
just artificial intelligence,
but natural intelligence too.
So,
20 years ago in the book you've written
on how the mind works,
you conjecture,
again my right to interpret things.
You can,
uh,
you can correct me if I'm wrong,
but you conjecture that human thought in
the brain may be a result of a now a
massive network of highly interconnected
neurons.
So from this,
uh,
interconnectivity and mergers thought
compared to artificial neural networks,
we should,
we use for machine learning today.
Is there something fundamentally more
complex,
mysterious,
even magical about the biological neural
networks versus the ones we've been
starting to use,
uh,
over the past 60 years and it become to
success in the past 10.
There is something a little bit
mysterious about the human neural
networks,
which is that each one of us who is a
neural network knows that we ourselves
are conscious,
a conscious,
not have a sense of registering our
surroundings or even registering our
internal state.
But in having subjective,
first person present tense experience.
That is when I see red,
it's not just different for green,
but it just,
there's,
there's a redness to it.
But I feel whether an artificial system
would experience that or not,
I don't know.
And I don't think I can know that.
That's why it's mysterious.
If we had a perfectly lifelike robot
that was behaviorally indistinguishable
from a human,
would we attribute consciousness to it
or a or ought we to attribute
consciousness to it and that's something
that it's a very hard to know.
But putting that aside,
putting aside that,
that largely philosophical question,
the question is,
is there some difference between the
hero human neural network and the ones
that we were building?
An artificial intelligence will mean
that we're on the current trajectory not
going to reach the point where we've got
a lifelike robot indistinguishable from
a human because the way their neural,
so-called neural networks are organized
are different from the way ours are
organized.
I think there's overlap,
but I think there are some,
some big differences that a current
neural networks current so called deep
learning systems are,
are in reality,
not all that deep that is,
they are very good at extracting high
order statistical regularities,
but most of the systems don't have a
semantic level,
a level of,
uh,
actual understanding of who did what to
whom.
Uh,
why,
where,
how things work,
what causes,
what else
do you think?
That kind of thing can emerge as it does
so artificial,
you're so much smaller,
the number of connections and so on and
the current human biological networks,
but do you think sort of go to go to
consciousness or to go to this higher
level semantic reasoning about things?
Do you think that kind of merge with
just a larger network with more richly
weirdly interconnected network?
Separate again,
consciousness,
because consciousness is even a matter
of complexity.
Really Weird one.
Yeah.
You could have,
you could,
you could sensibly asked the question of
whether shrimp conscious for example,
they're not terribly complex,
but maybe they feel pain.
So let's,
let's just put that one,
that part of it aside yet.
But,
uh,
I think sheer size of a neural network
is not enough to give it a structure and
knowledge,
but if it's suitably engineered then uh,
then why not?
That is we're neural networks.
Natural selection did a,
a,
a kind of equivalent of engineering of
our brains.
So I don't think there's anything
mysterious in the sense that no,
uh,
no system made it of silicon could ever
do what a human brain can do.
I think it's possible in principle,
whether it'll ever happen depends not
only on how clever we are in engineering
these systems,
but whether even we even want to,
whether that's even a sensible goal that
is,
you can ask the question,
is there any,
um,
locomotion system that is,
uh,
as,
as good as a human?
Well,
we kind of want to do better than a
human ultimately in terms of legged
locomotion.
Uh,
there's no reason that humans should be
our benchmark there.
They're tools that might be better in
some ways.
It may just be not as a,
maybe that we can't duplicate a natural
system because,
uh,
at some point it's so much cheaper to
use a natural system that we're not
going to invest more brainpower and
resources.
So for example,
we don't really have a subsequent exact
substitute for would still build houses
out of wood.
We still build furniture out of wood.
We liked the look.
We like the feel.
It's what has certain properties that
synthetic stones.
It's not that there's any magical and
mysterious about would a,
it's just that the extra steps of
duplicating everything about wood is
something we just haven't bothered
because we have what likewise say
cotton.
I mean,
I'm wearing cotton clothing now.
It feels much better than than
polyester.
It's not that cotton has something magic
in it and it's not that.
If there was that we couldn't ever
synthesize something exactly like
cotton,
but at some point it's just a.
it's just not worth it.
We've got cotton and likewise in the
case of human intelligence,
the goal of making an artificial system
that is exactly like the human brain is
a a goal that we probably known as going
to pursue to the bitter end,
I suspect because if you want tools that
do things better than humans,
you're not going to care whether it does
something like humans.
So for going to diagnosing cancer or
predicting the weather.
Why set humans as your benchmark
in in general?
I suspect you also believe that even if
the human should not be a benchmark and
we don't want to imitate humans in their
system.
There's a lot to be learned about how to
create an artificial intelligence system
by studying the human.
Yeah,
I,
I think that's right.
In the same way that to build flying
machines,
we want under the laws of aerodynamics
and including birds but not mimic the
birds,
but at the same loss,
uh,
you have a view on ai,
artificial intelligence and safety that,
uh,
from my perspective is refreshingly
rational or perhaps more importantly has
elements of positivity to it which I
think can be inspiring and empowering as
opposed to paralyzing for many people,
including AI researchers.
The eventual existential threat of ai is
obvious,
not only possible but obvious.
And for many others,
including AI researchers,
the threat is not obvious.
So Elon Musk is famously in the highly
concerned about ai camp,
saying things like ai is far more
dangerous than nuclear weapons and that
ai will likely destroy a human
civilization.
So in February you said that if Elon was
really serious about Ai,
the,
the threat of Ai,
he would stop building self driving cars
that he's doing very successful as part
of Tesla.
Then he said,
wow,
if even pinker doesn't understand the
difference between narrow ai,
like a car and general ai,
when the ladder literally has a million
times more compute power and an open
ended utility function,
humanity is in deep trouble.
So first,
what did you mean by the statement about
Ilan mosque should stop building self
driving cars if he's deeply concerned,
not the last time that Elon musk is
fired off in,
in temporary tweet.
We live in a world where a twitter has
power.
Yes.
Uh,
yeah.
I think the,
the,
um,
there are to a kinds of existential
threat that had been discussed in
connection with artificial intelligence
and I think that they're both
incoherent.
Uh,
one of them is a vague fear of ai
takeover that,
uh,
it just as we subjugated animals and
less technologically advanced peoples.
So if we build something that's more
advanced than us,
it will inevitably turn us into paths or
slaves or,
or a domesticated animal equivalence.
I think this confuses intelligence with
a will to power that.
It so happens that in the intelligence
system we are most familiar with namely
Homo Sapiens,
we are products of natural selection,
which is a competitive process and so
bundled together with our problem
solving capacity are a number of nasty
traits,
a dominance and a exploitation and
maximize nation of of power and glory
and resources and influence.
There's no reason to think that she or
problem solving capability.
We'll set that as one of its goals.
Its goals will be whatever we said its
goals as and as long as someone isn't
building a megalomanic maniacal
artificial intelligence,
there's no reason to think that it would
naturally evolve in that direction.
Now you might say,
well,
what if we gave it the goal of
maximizing its own power source?
That's a pretty stupid goal to give a a,
an autonomous system.
You don't give it that goal.
I mean that just self-evidently idiotic.
So if you look at the history of the
world,
there's been a lot of opportunities
where engineers could instill in a
system destructive power and they choose
not to because that's the natural
process of engineering.
Well,
except for weapons.
I mean,
if you're building a weapon,
it's goal is to destroy people.
Uh,
and so I think there are good reasons to
not not build certain kinds of weapons.
I think new building nuclear weapons was
a massive mistake,
a big problem.
Do you think.
So,
uh,
maybe pause on that because that is one
of the serious threats.
Do you think that,
uh,
it was a mistake in a sense that it
should have been stopped early on,
or do you think it's just an unfortunate
event of invention that this was
invented?
It was possible to stop,
I guess is the question.
It's hard to rewind the clock because of
course it was invented in the context of
World War II and the fear that the Nazis
might develop one first.
Then once it was initiated for that
reason,
it was,
it was hard to turn off,
especially since winning the war against
the Japanese and the Nazis was such an
overwhelming goal of every responsible
person that they were just nothing that
people wouldn't have done then to ensure
victory.
It's quite possible if world war two
hadn't happened,
that nuclear weapons wouldn't have been
invented,
we can't know,
um,
but I don't think it was a by any means
a necessity anymore than some of the
other weapon systems that were
envisioned but never implemented like
planes that would disperse poison gas
over cities like crop dusters or systems
to try to,
to,
uh,
create,
earthquakes and tsunamis and enemy
countries to weaponize the weather,
weaponize solar flares,
all kinds of crazy schemes that,
uh,
that,
that we thought the better of analogies
between nuclear weapons and artificial
intelligence are fundamentally misguided
because the whole point of nuclear
weapons is to destroy things.
The point of artificial intelligence is
not to destroy things.
So the analogy is,
is misleading.
So there's two artificial intelligence.
You mentioned the first one.
It was the intelligence or hungry.
Yeah.
The system that we designed ourselves
where we give it the goals goals are,
are external to the a means to attain
the goals.
If we don't design an artificially
intelligent system to maximize a
dominance,
than it won't maximize dominance.
A,
it just that we're so familiar with Homo
sapiens were these two traits come
bundled together,
particularly in men that we are apt to
confuse high intelligence with a,
a,
a will to power,
but that's just an error.
The other fear is that we'll be
collateral damage that will give a
artificial intelligence a goal like make
paperclips and it will pursue that goal
so brilliantly that before we can stop
it,
it turns us into paperclips,
will give it the goal of curing cancer
and it will turn us into Guinea pigs for
lethal experiments or give it the goal
of world peace in its conception of
world pieces.
No people,
therefore no fighting.
And so it will kill us all.
Now,
I think these are utterly fanciful.
In fact,
I think they're actually self-defeating.
They first of all,
assume that we're going to be so
brilliant that we can design an
artificial intelligence that can cure
cancer but so stupid that we don't
specify what we mean by curing cancer in
enough detail.
That it won't kill us in the process.
Uh,
and it assumes that the system will be
so smart that it can cure cancer,
but so idiotic that it doesn't,
can't figure out that what we mean by
curing cancer is not killing everyone.
So I think that the,
the collateral damage scenario,
the value alignment problem is,
uh,
is also based on a misconception.
So one of the challenges,
of course we don't know how to build
either system currently or are we even
close to knowing.
Of course those things can change
overnight,
but at this time theorizing about is
very challenging,
uh,
in,
in either direction.
So that's probably at the core of the
problem is without that ability to
reason about the real engineering things
here at hand is a,
your imagination runs away with things.
Exactly.
But let me sort of ask,
what do you think was the motivation and
the thought process of Isla Moscow?
I build autonomy vehicles.
I studied autonomous vehicles.
I studied tesla autopilot.
I think it is one of the greatest
currently application,
large scale applications of artificial
intelligence in the world.
It has a potentially a very positive
impact on society.
So how does a person who is creating
this very good quote unquote narrow ai
system also seem to be so concerned
about this other general ai?
What do you think is the motivation
there?
What do you think is the thing you'll
probably have to ask him,
but they're an and he is notoriously a
flamboyant,
impulsive to the,
as we have just seen to the detriment of
his own goals of,
of the,
the health of the company.
And so I,
I don't know what's going on in his
mind.
You probably have to ask him,
but I don't think the.
And I don't think the distinction
between special purpose ai and so-called
General Iai is relevant.
That in the same way that special
purpose ai is not going to do anything
conceivable in order to attain a goal.
All engineering systems have to,
uh,
are designed to trade off across
multiple goals where we build cars in
the first place.
We didn't forget to install breaks
because the goal of a car is to go fast.
Uh,
it occurred to people,
yes,
you want it to go fast,
but not always.
So you build in breaks to likewise,
if a car is going to be autonomous,
that doesn't and program it to take the
shortest route to the airport,
it's not going to take the diagonal and
mow down people and trees and fences
because that's the shortest route.
That's not what we mean by the shortest
route when we programmed it.
And that's just what an uh,
an intelligent system is.
By definition,
it takes into account multiple
constraints.
The same is true,
in fact even more true of so-called
general intelligence.
That is,
if it's genuinely intelligent,
it's not going to pursue some goal
singlemindedly omitting every other
consideration and collateral effect.
That's not artificial general
intelligence.
That's a,
that's artificial stupidity.
Um,
I agree with you,
by the way,
on the promise of autonomous vehicles
for improving human welfare.
I think it's spectacular and I'm
surprised at how little press coverage
notes that in the United States alone,
something like 40,000
people die every year on the highways,
fastly more than are killed by
terrorists.
And we spend.
You spent a trillion dollars on a war to
combat deaths by terrorism,
but half a dozen a year,
uh,
whereas every year and year out,
40,000
people are,
are massacred on the highways which
could be brought down to very close to
zero.
Uh,
so I'm,
I'm,
I'm with you on the humanitarian
benefit.
Let me just mention that it's,
as a person who is building these cars
that is a little bit offensive to me to
say that engine in years,
we'd be clueless enough not to engineer
safety into systems.
I often stay up at night thinking about
those 40,000
people that are dying and everything I
tried to engineer is to save those
people's lives.
So every new invention that I'm super
excited about every new,
uh,
and uh,
in,
in all the deep learning literature and
cvpr conferences and nips,
everything I'm super excited about is
all grounded in making it safe and help
people.
So I just don't see how that trajectory
can all of a sudden slip into a
situation where intelligence will be
highly negative.
I just want
you and I certainly agree on that and I
think that's only the beginning of the
potential humanitarian benefits of
artificial intelligence.
There has been enormous attention to
what are we going to do with the people
whose jobs are made obsolete by
artificial intelligence,
but very little attention given to the
fact that the jobs that are gonna be
made obsolete are horrible jobs.
The fact that people aren't going to be
picking crops and making beds and
driving trucks and mining coal.
These are soul deadening jobs and we
have a whole literature sympathizing
with the people stuck in menial mind
deadening a dangerous jobs if we can
eliminate them.
This is a fantastic boon to humanity.
Now,
granted,
we you solve one problem in.
There's another one,
namely how do we get these people a,
a decent income.
But if we're smart enough to invent
machines that can make beds and put away
dishes and uh,
and,
and handle hospital patients where I
think we're smart enough to figure out
how to redistribute income to apportion
some of the vast economic savings to the
the human beings who will no longer be
needed to,
to make better.
Okay.
Sam Harris says that it's obvious that
eventually ai will be an existential
risk,
is one of the people says it's obvious.
We don't know when the claim goes,
but eventually it's obvious and because
we don't know when we should worry about
it now,
it's a very interesting argument in my
eyes.
Um,
so how do,
how do we think about timescale?
How do we think about existential
threats when we don't really know so
little about the threat,
unlike nuclear weapons,
perhaps about this particular threat
that it could happen tomorrow,
right?
So,
but very likely won't likely to be 100
years away.
So how do we ignore it?
Do,
how do we talk about it?
Do we worry about it?
So what,
how do we think about those?
W W,
W,
what is it,
a threat that we can imagine it's within
the limits of our imagination,
but not within our limits of
understanding to sufficient to
accurately predict it.
Uh,
but what,
what is,
what is the
AI,
ai,
ai being the existential threat ai,
how enslaving us or turning us into
paperclips?
I think the most compelling from the Sam
Harris' perspective would be the
paperclip situation.
Yeah,
I mean,
I think,
I just think it's totally fanciful.
Ivy.
I don't build a system.
Don't give,
don't.
First of all,
uh,
the code of engineering is you don't
implement a system with massive control
before testing it.
Now perhaps the culture of engineering
will radically change then I would
worry,
but I don't see any signs that engineers
will suddenly do idiotic things like put
a,
uh,
an electrical power plant in control of
a system that they haven't tested,
uh,
first,
or all of these scenarios.
Not only imagine a,
um,
almost a magically powered intelligence
including things like cure cancer,
which is probably an incoherent goal
because there's so many different kinds
of cancer or bring about world peace.
I mean,
how do you even specify that as a goal,
but the scenario is also imagined some
degree of control of every molecule in
the universe,
uh,
which not only is itself unlikely,
but we would not start to connect these
systems to a infrastructure without a,
without testing as we would any kind of
system.
There may be some engineers will be
you're responsible and we need legal and
a regulatory and legal responsibility
implemented so that engineers don't do
things that are stupid by their own
standards.
But the,
uh,
I've never seen enough of a plausible
scenario of a existential threat to
devote large amounts of brain power to,
to forestall it.
You believe in
sort of the power and mass of the
engineering of reason as the arguing
your latest book of reason and science
and sort of be the very thing that
guides the development of new
technology.
So it's safe and also keeps us safe.
Yeah.
If the same and you know,
granted that same culture of safety that
currently is part of the engineering
mindset for airplanes,
for example.
So yeah,
I don't think that,
that,
uh,
that should be thrown out the window
and,
uh,
that untested,
all powerful systems should be suddenly
implemented,
but there's no reason to think they are.
And in fact,
if you look at the progress of
artificial intelligence,
it's been,
it's been impressive,
especially in the last 10 years or so,
but the idea that suddenly there'll be a
step function that all of a sudden
before we know it,
it will be,
oh,
powerful.
That there'll be some kind of recursive
self improvement,
some kind of a foom,
uh,
is also a fanciful.
We certainly,
by the technology that we,
that we're now impresses us,
such as deep learning where you train
something on a hundreds of thousands or
millions of examples.
They're not hundreds of thousands of
problems of which curing cancer is a
typical example.
Uh,
and so the kind of techniques that have
allowed a ai too increased in the last
five years are not the kind that are
gonna lead to this fantasy of,
uh,
of,
of exponential sudden self improvement.
So it's,
I think it's kind of a magical thinking.
It's not based on our understanding of
how ai actually works.
Now give me a chance here.
So you said fanciful,
magical thinking.
In his Ted talk,
Sam Harris says that thinking about ai
killing all human civilization is
somehow fun intellectually.
Now I have to say as a scientist
engineer,
I don't find it fun,
but when I'm having beer with my
friends,
there is indeed something fun and
appealing about it.
Like talking about an episode of Black
Mirror,
considering if a large media or is
headed towards her,
we were just told a large media is
headed towards earth,
something like this.
And can you relate to this sense of fun
and do you understand the psychology of
it?
Good question.
Uh,
I,
I personally don't find it fun.
Um,
I find it kind of a actually a waste of
time because there are genuine threats
that we ought to be thinking about,
like,
like pandemics,
like a cybersecurity vulnerabilities.
I'm like the possibility of nuclear war
and certainly climate change is enough
to fill that many,
uh,
conversations without.
And I think they're,
I think Sam did put his finger on
something,
namely that there is a community,
uh,
sometimes called the rationality
community that delights in using it's
brain power to come up with scenarios
that would not occur to me are mortals
to,
to so the less cerebral people.
So there is a kind of intellectual
thrill and finding new things to worry
about that no one has a worried about
yet.
I actually think though,
that it's not only,
that is a kind of fun that doesn't give
me particular pleasure,
uh,
but I think there can be a pernicious
side to it,
namely that you overcome people with
such a dread,
such fatalism that there's so many ways
to,
uh,
to die,
to annihilate our civilization that we
may as well enjoy life while we can.
There's nothing we can do about it.
If climate change doesn't do us in,
then runaway robots will.
So,
uh,
what,
let's enjoy ourselves now,
we got to prioritize.
We have to look at threats that are
close to certainty,
such as climate change,
and distinguish those from ones that are
merely imaginable.
But with infinitesimal probabilities,
and we have to take into account
people's worry budget,
you can't worry about everything and if
you so dread and fear and terror and
numb and fatalism,
it can lead to a kind of numbness while
they just,
these problems are overwhelming and the
engineers are just going to kill us all.
Um,
so,
uh,
let's either destroy the entire
infrastructure of science technology or
let's just enjoy life while we can.
So there's a certain line of worrying,
which I'm worried about a lot of things
engineering,
there's a certain line of worry when you
cross a law to cross a that it becomes
paralyzing fear as opposed to productive
here.
And that's kind of what I'm
highlighting.
Exactly right.
And,
and we've seen some,
uh,
we know that human effort is not well
calibrated against risk in that because
a basic tenant of cognitive psychology
is that a perception of risk and his
perception of fear.
It's driven by imagine ability not by
data.
Uh,
and so we miss allocate fast amounts of
resources to avoiding terrorism,
which kills on average about six
Americans a year with a one exception of
nine slash 11.
Uh,
we invade countries,
we invent an entire new departments of
government with massive,
massive expenditure of resources in
life's to defend ourselves against a
trivial risk,
uh,
whereas guaranteed risks,
and you mentioned as one of them is,
you mentioned traffic fatalities,
uh,
and even risks that are,
I'm not here but are plausible enough to
worry about like pandemics,
like nuclear war received far too little
attention,
the in presidential debates.
There's no discussion of how to minimize
the risk of,
of nuclear war,
lots of discussion of terrorism,
for example.
Uh,
and,
and so we,
I think it's essential to calibrate our
budget of fear,
worry,
concern,
planning to the,
uh,
actual probability of a,
of harm.
Yep.
So let me ask this then,
this question.
So speaking of imagine an ability,
you said that it's important to think
about reason.
And one of my favorite people who,
who likes to dip into the outskirts of
reason,
uh,
through fascinating exploration of his
imagination is Joe Rogan.
Oh yes.
Uh,
you,
uh,
so who has three reasons to believe a
lot of conspiracies and through a reason
has stripped away a lot of his beliefs
in that way.
So it's fascinating actually to watch
him through rationality.
Kinda throw away the ideas.
Have a big foot.
And um,
nine slash 11,
I'm not sure exactly the trails.
I don't know what he believes,
but he no longer believed in.
That's all right.
No,
he's,
he's become a real force for,
uh,
for Greg.
Yep.
So you were on the Joe Rogan podcast in
February and had a fascinating
conversation.
But as far as I remember,
didn't talk much about artificial
intelligence.
I will be on this podcast and a couple
weeks,
joe is very much concerned about
existential threat of Ai.
I'm not sure if you're a.
This is why I was hoping that you will
get into that topic.
And in this way,
he represents quite a lot of people who
look at the topic of Ai from 10,000
foot level.
So as an exercise of a communication,
you said it's important to be rational
and reason about these things.
Let me ask,
if you were to coach me as an ai
researcher about how to speak to Joe and
the general public about Ai,
what would you advise?
Well,
like,
uh,
the short answer would be to read the
sections that I wrote in an enlightened
about ai,
but longer reason would be I think to
emphasize,
and I think you're very well positioned
as an engineer to remind people about
the culture of engineering,
that it really is a safety oriented.
That another discussion in enlightenment
now I plot,
uh,
rates of accidental death from various
causes,
plane crashes,
car crashes,
occupational accidents,
even death by lightning strikes.
And they all plummet because the culture
of engineering is how do you squeeze out
the,
uh,
the lethal risks,
death by fire,
death by drowning,
death by a fixation.
All them drastically declined because of
advances in engineering.
Then I got to say,
I did not appreciate until I saw those
graphs,
and it is because exactly people like
you who stay up at night thinking,
oh my God,
is what am I,
what I'm,
what I'm inventing likely to hurt people
and to deploy ingenuity to prevent that
from happening.
Now I'm not an engineer,
although I spent 22 years at Mit,
so I know something about the culture of
engineering,
my understanding that this is the way,
this is what you think if you're an
engineer and it's essential that that
culture not be suddenly switched off
when it comes to artificial intelligence
so that,
that,
that could be a problem.
But is there any reason to think it
would be switched off?
Think so and one.
There's not enough engineers speaking up
for this way,
for this.
The excitement for,
uh,
the positive view of human nature,
what you're trying to create,
the positivity,
like everything we try to invent is
trying to do good for the world.
But let me ask you about the psychology
of negativity.
It seems just objectively not
considering the topic.
It seems that being negative about the
future,
it makes you sound smarter than being
positive about the future.
It regardless of topic.
Am I correct in this observation?
And if so,
why do you think
that is?
Yeah,
I think I,
I think there is that a phenomenon that
as Tom Lehrer,
the Sandra said,
always predict the worst and you'll be
hailed as a profit.
Maybe part of our overall negativity
bias.
We are,
as a species more attuned to the
negative than the positive.
We dread losses more than we enjoy gains
and uh,
that may might open up a space for a
profits to remind us of harms and risks
and losses that we may have overlooked.
Uh,
so I think they're,
they're,
uh,
they're there.
Is that a symmetry?
So you've written some of my favorite
books all over the place.
So starting from enlightenment now to,
uh,
the better angels of our nature.
Blank slate,
how the mind works,
the one about language language
instinct,
a Bill Gates big fan to a set of your
most recent book that it's my new
favorite book of all time.
So for you as an author,
what was the book early on in your life
that had a profound impact on the way
you saw the world?
Certainly this book enlightened me now
is influenced by David Deutsch is the
beginning of infinity,
have rather deep reflection on a
knowledge and the power of knowledge to
improve the human condition.
Uh,
the end with bits of wisdom such as the
problems are inevitable,
but problems are solvable given the
right knowledge and that solutions
create new problems that have to be
solved in their turn.
That's,
I think,
a kind of wisdom about the human
condition that influenced the writing of
this book.
There's some books that are excellent
but obscure,
some of which I have on my,
uh,
I'm on a page of my website and I read a
book called the history of force self
published by a political scientist named
James Payne on the historical decline of
violence.
And that was one of the inspirations for
the better angels of our nature.
Uh,
the,
um,
what about early on back when you're
maybe a,
is a book called one,
two,
three infinity.
When I was a young adult,
I read that book by George Gamma off the
physicist,
very accessible and humorous
explanations of relativity of a number
theory of a dimentionality high,
multiple dimensional spaces,
uh,
in a,
in a way that I think is still
delightful.
Seventy years after it was published,
I liked the time life science series.
These were books that would arrive every
month that my mother subscribe to each
one on a different topic.
A one would be on,
on electricity.
What would it be on forests wonder
beyond my evolution.
And then one was on the mind and I was
just intrigued that there could be a
science of mind and that that book I
would a site as an influence as well.
Then later on,
you fell in love with the idea of
studying the mind.
It was,
that's one thing that grabbed you.
It was one of the things I would say,
um,
the,
uh,
I read,
as a college student.
The book reflections on language by Noam
Chomsky spent most of his career here at
Mit.
Uh,
Richard Dawkins,
two books,
the blind watchmaker and the selfish
gene were enormously influential partly
for mainly for the content,
but also for the writing style,
the ability to explain abstract concepts
in lively pros,
Stephen j Dot Gould's first collection
ever since Darwin.
Also a excellent example of,
of our life.
We writing a George Miller,
psychologists that most psychologists
that are familiar with came up with the
idea that human memory has a capacity of
a seven plus or minus two chunks and
supposedly his biggest claim to fame,
but he wrote a couple of books on
language and communication that I had
made as an undergraduate.
Again,
beautifully written and,
uh,
intellectually deep.
Wonderful.
Steven,
thank you so much for taking the time
today.
My pleasure.
Thanks a lot.